tel tutti ragazzi e benvenuto a questo
nuovo video sono falli j
oggi si riparte con un video al giorno
raga oggi e domenica si parte con happy
meals sarei dovuto ripartire domani con
un video al giorno perché domani esce lo
speciale 150 mila iscritti e quindi
ragazzi direi di iniziare prima che le
mie intro di un'ora occupino tutto il
video inizia da e da un secolo che non
accendo è più vestini nomi dico forme si
gioca su altro come prima lo ragazzi
dobbiamo iniziare e far vedere che
nonostante la linea è caduta per due
settimane non ho perso il mio tocco da
spadaccino professionista vai ad che
cazzo fai a buon porto al massacro tutti
quanti i quattro secondi va così vai
così
oh mio dio va bene dare sondati tutti
giù tranne luke lo bel [ __ ] volte
non riesco a prenderla quella ragazza
impossibile grande allora manca è il
nonno ciak e poi devo prendere no fermo
manco york lo prendo lo stesso con lo
stronzo di merda se che cazzo successo
execution cos'è chiusa siamo cos'è cos'è
sta roba tra l'altro lato pistola lio
che era sul comodino la prossima volta
lascino ordini giocattoli pardes jump
eva che stava faccio perché mi ispirava
ad hoc o non lasciatela che non abbiamo
colorato
goyer conto della facies jump eva save
money replay
sempre sabato 1 e piccini ci metto anche
la musica
cosa devo fare qui
che cazzo dici è stato dato
[Musica]
no non cerca proponi mal di testa
presumo cos'è sta roba
vai no no non succhiarsi il pollice
scappa ma sono io il mostro no ai peso
di essere non un ciak
c'è chi cazzo sta non o mio dio va bene
sei ancora mal di testa dapprima sulle
mai così io portai nato alla mano segui
il tuo vj e che sta succendo chi cazzo
ma ci sono cioè sembra colori nightmare
before christmas che cazzo va bene c'è
stata sto vincendo così sto guardando la
gente con le mani ragazzi cos'è questo
mi spiano un casino il nome così ma mi
sa che uno swing con indiana jones no
che figo cioè qua ci vuole la musica
indiana jones raga forse l'ha fatta
partire nel momento sbagliato voi adesso
è che sentite è forse la musica di
indiana jones non mi conviene tanto
visto che è sto morendo per adesso ce
l'ho fatta che non messo la musica bene
vai vai vai così grande direi che
possiamo rifarlo a partire
[Musica]
secret agent steve gestiva un agente
segreto io non lo sapevo cioè fatemi
capire ma che razza l'agente segreto
sarebbe steve siamo appena partiti già è
stato scoperto che senso ha questo mi
sta ingrossando maledizione togli il tuo
pene dal mio penice non ha senso
puoi fare fargli vedere chi sei
ora abbiamo cos'è sta roba cioè non ciak
in bocca o no perfetto non c'è che
partito fosse pro sesto livello un asse
ancora non ho ciak
io sono scampata una mina per miracolo
in poche parole by cos'è
dobbiamo saltare grande scrive va bene
allora come agente segreto fai cagare ma
come ninja sei un fenomeno job to the
peak traction point perfetto ad un punto
di estrazione vai così stefano
[Musica]
temple runner cosa temporanea tipo
temporaneo forse non ci posso credere
credo che sia una sorta di tempo avranno
una roba del genere non lo so cosa che
mi sta seguendo cioè non c'è non c'è
nessuno che mi serve brake oddio buoni
dice se posso solo il casco va bene vai
così che però che pro no no no no ok mi
ha scassato la porta dietro ma sono
ancora vivo e così vai così normalizzerà
banco fi che già facciamo gli occhi
togliti non vedo il cazzo grande ma
[ __ ] liuc è colpa tua brutto
stronzo che cazzo è ragazzi a ok
perfetto sono pedobear devo a devo
andare avanti perfetto ce lo siamo mai
così ai ragazzi dobbiamo stuprare il
dubbio se lo troviamo la iarc cercherà
janka è perfetto
è finito così fanny survival s'aspetta
mai steve no liberati steve liberati una
pallina o cazzo dai libretti adesso c'è
adesso c'è malizia e [ __ ] va bene
così ho vinto la lynx warbear questo lo
voglio fare
ho paura di che colpa ai con eti se vai
dove siamo cioè explorer chiari penso
anche ai ragazzi devo riuscire a battere
il suo tizio lo sai dove traffico la
spada lo sai dovete la piccola spada lo
sai
mio zio ma la ragazzina e macabro sta
col mio dio lo squartatore per vento
ragazzi questo è un mio calzino perché
mi stanno usando il piede da solo da
gala che mi è venuto in mente che nel
frattempo che sono stato assente si
giorni che non c'era lina non ho giocato
nessun livello di fa vj non so quanti ne
sono usciti nel frattempo la vallata per
fa vj cazzo di rafah vicissimo molto dai
sempre il meglio di te grazie mille devo
riuscire a fare più sesta ci sono vai
piano noi non vanno piano vado veloce
quanto mi pare cos'è dove sono sono
spopolando ma cazzo non ti puoi fare un
bagno né gli ananas ed in un assenso
epic boltro per fa vj raga lo faccio
perché non ancora fatti purtroppo oggi
sei un mito il grazie mille e sacchetto
se queste ferite il ragga quello che fai
livelli di un fenomeno gli occhi one dai
lo sa lo faccio perché non vedo l'ora
diciamo che quando uk si scuote mille
pezzi una liberazione
help cosa cioè mi fai così grande la
morte è andato a minchia ce la possiamo
fare la caccia posso fare
cos'è musella nutella ha vinto la
nutella ho vinto
dove eccola è la stella pochi j che figo
che ticket ma no
mario no perche che mario deve rompere
il cazzo anche sua pipa vj super imposti
come facciamo questo perché è non solo
di prima non ci sono circoli o quello
era veramente impossibile raga non ci
credo
c'è un po vi ho fatto solo benissimo
fanno fatto questo livello perché so che
a te facciamo molto impossible iv alicia
puoi fare è me lo chiedi anche ragazze
la posso fare voi così la gamma la gamma
la gamma neanche la gamba questo è
quello giusto me lo sento una freccia
nel culo non mi fermerà ce la possiamo
fare possiamo fare sì sì sì no no no non
è possibile
ragazzi da farsi si è così e ce l'ho
fatta mio addio comunque ragazzi
concluso qui l'episodio vi ricordo che
domani comunque c'è lo speciale 105 min
city anche se non ci siamo proprio
arrivati comunque lo speciale lo faccio
lo stesso con questo video è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come non i video
tanto nella descrizione
se non siete iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
rivediamo un prossimo video bene ragazzi
[Musica]